no break no break no break no break no
break no break no break up break is for
cows you ever noticed how things are
just getting crazier out there
especially when it comes to mobile ants
[Music]
bad mobile game commercials we've all
seen them no I'm not talking about
peopIe pixelating how dare you but the
latest addition to annoying and bad
commercial and I don't even want to say
the name of the game but I guess I have
to
it's Lily Garden what is this freaking
ad I found on Facebook
this is posted in August I assume that
slowly
Lily's garden you want to play that game
you want to play that game
so we've seen obscure and strange app
commercials that makes no sense but it's
like they're trying to tell a story but
I can't help but think why it's like
watching the latest Star Wars film okay
things are happening but why let's watch
some more Lily's garden ants I don't he
looks like more than the neighbor Jesus
Christ Blaine he says keep riding on
that [ __ ] but he can he has literally
not stopped ever since he he's thinking
about the child and the consequences
cool
[Music]
did Lily just do that okay now I feel
less bad about Lily slapping her mom
imagine making that with your daughter's
ex-husband and then going she looks like
she could go super saiyan so he'd make
sense what you slapped me oh that's the
actual game like we've seen so far
pregnancy cheat lice domestic violence
but what is the game play [ __ ] that
does not even look like Lily it better
not be in video this better not be
bejeweled match two or more tiles same
color where's the pregnancy when's that
pregnancy [ __ ] I'm gonna say it live is
it King yo you feel bad for her
well they made a follow-up commercial
for whatever reason
[Music]
we know the story he left but what we
didn't know oh my god but if she
pretended to be pregnant to get rid of
the guy then surely she should not slap
her mother for making out with him
that's something to think about now yes
they're trying to do a story they're
trying to do an epic thing about the
video game ads I get it but then they
took it into the natural direction
perhaps which is sexualizing this is
what we need to do we recruited PI's
picks link we need to sexualize all the
pics links cuz clearly this is one made
the whole thing blew up this is when I
first saw about Lily's garden it's this
god-awful commercial and if you haven't
seen it already I apologize for showing
it to you
I don't mean to go away I was gonna
point out can you not just imprint the
touch hint you know it doesn't matter
[Music]
what's the rating of this game I need to
understand his mother can Apple band
poop thee but they allow this family
it's a family game for bus
that's so weird that's like having
[ __ ] sexy Angry Birds what's things
give spongebob a bunch it's hits I don't
what are you doing stop it this is the
gameplay
there's no shaking over gana there's no
shaking over Ghana this commercial was
in fact so popular they made another one
oh they got candles and wine do you
wanna play Lily's garden now hmm not
convinced now maybe you want to play
Lily's garden you look like you wanna
play Leigh Leigh's garden they brought
in a guest star Whitney as Whitney for
that one that's interesting what's next
are they gonna shove Lily through a meat
grinder cuz then maybe I'll consider
buying the game it's for for blood after
all she puts the hole in holidays that's
Lily everyone they keep sexualizing Lily
and ID I think it's despicable it makes
me angry Lily's at it again with the ok
sign penis emoji what do we got
oh that's that's guest-star Whitney with
absolute Chad no come on
[Music]
this game is for four plus it's family
rated this is terrible the game used to
be good what the hell happened what are
you talking about they actually used to
be a game involved so is this before or
after her pregnancy people need to know
who is the father
if Lily wasn't out doing the garland I
swear to god she'd be on twitch begging
begging I know it so I'm not gonna show
this commercial because it's age
restricted it's a family game everyone
family game for four year plus poopd
however we can't have that game this is
actually really interesting
I wonder if Apple or Google are gonna
change their terms of service in a way
on looking at how they're marketing the
game because obviously they're just
looking at what the game itself is and
they're like okay it's fine I'm just
very I'm just very very very confused
and at the same time not really I get it
lily has an instagram which is
surprisingly not that bad I'd expect to
see at least a couple yoga pant shots or
oh there is okay nevermind
[Music]
my god Lily kissed her ex-husband that's
crazy
[Music]
Lily's a [ __ ] I'm not slut-shaming
but I'll she it a different story and
you can say that again
new year new drama same mama
oh my god what is happening
[Music]
oh my god that's what you get Lilly you
in your garden yeah go back to gardening
big Danish company are you [ __ ]
weirdos I knew it anytime daint Denmark
there's something you know they're up to
no good I knew I knew it I firmly
believe that the game just access to
fund ease and making shorts really what
they're passionate about is telling a
story and they do that so well
[Music]
now why would I click play oh man
when the gameplay is in vigil its felt
like when you were a kid and video games
used to be so differently market them
because graphic point is good so you'd
get look he's insane cover art like this
and you're like well that's so cool
super muscular babe and boob and wizard
and thing and then you play the game and
it's like oh oh oh that's the gameplay
it's actually quite good but still
that's what this is they're using the
same technique and they are tricking the
four-year-old let's see what these
weirdos have I else have done
oh cool they also have the game called
cookie cats blast which is the exact
same gameplay absolutely scarred wow
that's so fun why don't you sexualize
cookie cat blast instead and leave Lily
out of this
no jokes aside who cares really it's
this funny and bizarre and it gets
people to talk about it and that's the
point of advertising really it's nothing
new and I'm not woke or anything - for
pointing it out people know this it's
just fun I don't really have a problem
with it even though I hate Lily and hope
she dies in a fire because you two have
their new cyberbully
harassment thing right and there's that
look at this creatures teeth
they're so disgusting I wonder if I can
get away with that that's it for this
video hope you guys enjoyed if you did
smash like and brake be like bruh I
really don't know what I'm doing help me
you haven't been training on pixel ins
we'll get on it cuz ranked PvP matches
are live don't call yourself a gamer
unless you're top here in PewDiePie's
picks links climb the tiers get Fame
points make 19 year olds cry and unlock
new arenas epic oh did I mention their
pics links you're welcome
[Music]
you